really happy to be here really thanks
for you know him letting me actually
stand up here and talk to you with had
somebody pulling me off but I did speak
in a class before with Richard and was
really cool to see how many similar
things are going on not only on an
academic level but also on the business
side Matt from Stanford but definitely
have a lot of background working with
people from Stanford and as well as in
my business doing venture right now as
well as in Google before so just a
little bit more about me as to what
Richard was saying I started my my
business my career actually in banking
and he wrote me a mid nineties or so and
then moved to startup world end of the
90s or so and then moved out to the Bay
Area in 2000 where I started at Google
and at that time international was you
know it was more of a luxury for a
company it wasn't really a main part of
the business and then about six months
into the job they said you know can you
help us you know monetize search
overseas and start you know you know
looking at ways to expand and it was
sort of a side project but then we saw
there was so much traffic coming in from
overseas areas and you know as the
internet was growing the index was
growing and you know more and more
searches were being done overseas and
then I moved my focus more to Asia and
of course at the time with Silicon
Valley companies Asia was a very risky
area I mean China obviously with its you
know you know walled gardens and then
and in Korea you know the operators and
conglomerates are kind of running
everything but over time you know search
became more of a main business unit for
people and for companies over there and
you know began to grow you know Google's
presence or over time and kept those
relationships and then afterwards coming
back to the valley started seeing a lot
of entrepreneurs that wanted to leverage
my experience in Asia with different
countries there that I had been doing
business in and with their own business
and now with mobile exploding everywhere
it's become sort of the main you know in
some cases the first stage of their
business going to Asia first because
Mobile is very much everywhere there
especially Android and also the other
way so we see a lot of Asian money and
entrepreneurs wanting to come to the
valley because that's considered the
gold standard of what you know where to
launch your business so you know through
these networks both here in in Asia I've
been sort of bridging that and working
closely with Professor Dasher as well
he's been a big help and without further
ado I guess we will
pointed over to Sherman and afterwards
have a quick talk about both of our
experiences and open it up to you for a
Q&A thanks David
all right um I think my story's a little
bit different and let me get this back
up onto the screen I'm Sherman Lee and
as dr. Dasher mentioned I actually grew
up in America and I'm going to kind of
start a little bit about why I'm an
outsider to Korea and how I ended up
going there okay
these prezi's are I'm too cool alright
why it's a little different I'm actually
chinese-american I'm not Korean and I
ended up in Korea for the last ten years
I graduated here in 2003 I was a
computer systems engineering major that
got rid of it already and I didn't stay
here I'm I think the only guy in my
class he doesn't work for David at
Google at that time and so when I came
out of college I started my first
company directly in Korea and we sold it
in 2005 the company is called the VIX
our after that I returned into the Bay
Area you know did some consulting and
then I was invited back to Korea with
Softbank of interest Korea and Oh 8 and
I was an entrepreneur in residence there
and became the CEO and CFO of answers my
second startup which was acquired at the
end of 2011 so currently I have a couple
roles I run the US subsidiary of answers
which is now Korea Telecom subsidiary
and also soompi.com which is their k-pop
k-pop site you know what they call how
you which is Korean Wave site and we're
all over the world we have French
versions Portuguese versions and so
forth okay so that's kind of my
background and I'm kind of gonna go
through all these things and how I ended
up in this career path the questions I'm
always asked you know as the the Chinese
guy in Korea trying to do startups is
how did I become an entrepreneur and why
Korea I mean the story in China and
Japan it's such strong store in
Southeast Asia in India but all out of
all places ten years ago why Korea now
it's easy to see
you know there's all this technology in
Korea you guys you know the best phones
are coming out of there the best
consumer electronics 10 years ago that
wasn't the case and then how is
entrepreneurship in Asia different like
why didn't I stay here in the Silicon
Valley and a lot of times how can we do
that how can you go through that journey
of starting company in Asia after being
trained here and luring the perspective
of the local industries okay so my first
startup in Korea at Vic's are this is
kind of what happened as dr. Decker
mentioned through 2000 in 2002 I was
involved in the Asia Pacific student
entrepreneurship society now aces it's
still alive now which I'm very happy to
say a couple members are here and Asus
is really a student organization we've
kept a completely student-run and they
organized two conferences a year one at
Stanford for entire week and another in
Asia and students from universities in
Japan and Hong Kong and Singapore they
all come to Stanford and then students
here all go over to Asia to meet each
other and you know the talk shop or
learned about each other's experiences
in college now by doing that of course
you meet a lot of people but you didn't
think you'd meet and one of the members
there was studying at heist which is the
Korea advanced Institute of Science and
Technology and a lot of you know like a
lead professor Terman was an early
member of Caixa stablishment in korea
and he reached out to us with an idea to
basically build go to my pc which is
something you guys you know it was
founded also around the same time in
America and WebEx and at that time is
very exciting so he reached out to me
and all the Aces friends and said well
why don't you come join me you know I
was like well maybe maybe I want to go
to another big company here maybe I
should stay in Silicon Valley um and
then we want a business plan competition
we got free incubators space in the
university we're like alright let's do
this
so I graduate day after I graduated I
went to Korea and hice is actually not
in Seoul it's two hours south of Seoul
in a town called tej on the
tried to make it into industrial park
there's a lot of government funding
there the university was established in
the model of Stanford and again they
really try to nurture this and at the
time we got some very small seed funding
and started our company okay from there
we actually formed a small team of eight
students engineers around this one
patent and one idea to build remote
control and remote control and go to my
PC again is controlling a computer over
the Internet and of course we had to
make it a web-based solution so it's not
like VNC and those kind of Linux based
solutions we didn't pay ourselves very
much out of the initial funding just
enough to afford some ramen and live in
the town next door again my first
apartment in Korea was $250 a month the
running water didn't run so well and you
know a lot of those kind of things but
it was a lot of fun and I think the only
time in my life I could do that was when
I was 23 so that was a good choice I
think at the time that being said we
still ran out of money and we spent six
months pitching to strategic VCS at the
time there weren't a lot of Angels right
there's a lot of VCS that are attached
to big companies through Samsung
Ventures there's SK Ventures there's
those kind of companies um there's a lot
of investment arms that banks so we went
to all the big banks in Korea so this is
a KB Bank or woody bank and then of
course we try to call everyone who could
be interested and had money to write us
a check we actually signed a term sheet
after six months we celebrated then the
deal fell through and they said I don't
know if we want to invest in a bunch of
kids so then we ran out of money by
January 2004 and we actually took out a
bank loans private loans and we became
really desperate I mean you gotta
imagine we're eight kids we didn't know
what to do and no one wants to give us
money so one of the VC firms firm called
saram ventures and it's actually they
invested early on dialpad I don't know
if you guys remember the name that's
sold to Yahoo so that group actually
would are like okay we're going to
invest in your company but a very low
valuation and Softbank ventures layer
joined again there's a lot of parts of
the steel structure that we didn't know
about we were too young to understand it
we had some of the angel round but again
part of it was in corporate bonds the
way converted we just didn't understand
enough of it to really know how it all
worked and that kind of ended up being a
problem for us later on but anyway we
took the money because we had no choice
and we created that go to my pc type
service in Korea we called it net row
and it was a freemium model it became
number one in users very quickly but
wasn't profitable for us because no one
was upgrading to the premium accounts
and this is like in 2003 in Korea you
know no one wants to pay for it so we
were like well we need a big name we cut
a deal with one of the telecom providers
and we reached kind of a revenue share
agreement with LG's day comm which is
their telecom arm at the time and we
tried to sell a remote support solution
even with LG they common that deal we
still failed to become profitable it's
you know freemium at the time was very
new paying for it when you could get
most of what you need for free was very
hard to accomplish and one more wrinkle
after 2 years our entire team had to go
to the Korean military so this was
something we didn't anticipate because
when we ran we when we started the
company most the kids are still students
now while you're student in Korea you're
covered you don't have to go to military
but they thought that as long as they
kind of did some classes they can be
covered by 2005 everyone got a slip you
can't get out of it one of the guys
actually served in Iraq anyway everyone
had to go to military out of the 8
people on our team it's just myself we
didn't have to go and a female designer
so we're like well what are we going to
do we can still survive we're not doing
great
and everyone has to go to military so we
decided to close up shop and so after
two two and a half years of running this
company we actually sold it to LG and
their unit and actually to date it's
still the number one service of its kind
in Korea which is why you don't go to
creating someone's using GoToMyPC right
um but it's never really became such a
big hit there and we wrapped up our
business now of course when we sold the
company all the money plus interest went
back to our investors again we also
didn't know as better declare bankruptcy
you might get something out you know
again we didn't know how this all worked
sir investors like to slot from that but
I also learned a lot of lessons from
those two and a half years even though I
didn't get as much financially out of it
don't take bank bank or private loans if
you have a choice it's a it's tough and
you're sweating a lot when you do that
it was really important I think choosing
the VCS wisely like at the time we were
impressed by some names by the way saram
ventures approached us because they had
admit a funded dialpad but there are
horror stories and we kind of lived
through some of it and why I say that is
that by the time we're wrapping up the
company you know we get offers of well
you guys you know we didn't return much
money to us you have to work for us
you're reliable to work for us for years
you know all those kinds of things it's
for real that's they asked me to do that
and I almost signed a contract said hey
don't worry about the loan you're gonna
have to work the next five years to pay
it off and they're gonna take off a
certain amount from your salary I mean I
was staring at this contract going oh my
goodness what am I gonna do right I'm do
I have to you again ask your lawyers you
know make sure you do all these things
probably and really choose your PC's
wisely if they're the kind of people and
you squeeze you for every dime that's a
really bad way to run a business that's
the other part is don't celebrate after
sighing ello eyes or term sheets that
stuff yeah we you know we went out and
got a ball whiskey were like yes we did
it um and then they pulled it right so
one of the banks that we talked to
pulled it our valuation that we actually
ended up taking months later was a third
of what we thought we would get same for
the dollar amount fourth obviously be
aware of the Korean military requirement
I didn't know that going in had all the
guys I was working for need to go at
some point I didn't know that and also
business malls should be chosen
differently freemium at the time for
this kind of productivity type service
wasn't a good choice for us um it
actually freemium in Korea is really
powerful for the gaming industry I think
for enterprise it wasn't very great
great and you know we'll talk about this
more later but I think that the way you
choose a business mall in Korea when
you're trying to do this is a very
different okay so that's kind of my
first thing so after I ended up back at
home in Zuckerberg by the way his class
of 2003 and I realized I was not him
so I went home to San Francisco and all
my buddies were at Facebook or Google
and I had to go be a consultant for a
firm you know I had actually learned
enough from my time in Korea so I did
some strategy consulting especially
about internationally mainly working
until actually at the time they were
very excited about media PCs in the
Intel vive I don't know if you guys
remember that and I did a lot of work
there two to three years of building
powerpoints and Excel spreadsheets I got
a little bit bored after the exciting
two and a half years I had it in Korea
however it was really nice to have a
paycheck so I didn't know what to do
with my career and by this time I was
five six years out of college it's a
good time to go to business school
potentially go to a consulting firm like
the offers I had rejected when I was
coming out of school and that's not my
Dropbox I had offers to join one of the
clients I was working with you know big
firm shy work for start-up at that time
or you know join a cool company like
Google I guess after a couple years
being back here the pace is different
and I really wanted to be back in Asia
not because it's necessarily better for
my career it's just because it was more
interesting so as luck would have it
someone I kind of known and again
someone else from Caixa he founded a
company in 2007 by winning a research
grant from the Korean government and at
this time I actually returned to Korea
and I was an entrepreneur and residents
for soft
ventures and because Safin can invest in
her first company the CEO invited me
back he said you know I want to be part
of your next company you're old enough
now and you might be a little bit wiser
than the first time so I want to put
money again but I actually did that only
for about four or five months before I
met up with Jack who started answers and
we put the company together you know he
had just won a research grant we
actually put together the first round of
funding the series a we had angel
financing from bone angels and I joined
as a founding member and by middle of
2008 you know again we had brought in
money we had put together the team we
started growing our business now why
it's called answers it's entertainment
answers we started as a video search
engine and we really thought we're going
to become the Google for video search
the strength of our company is
technology called video fingerprinting
if you're familiar with the space
there's watermarking fingerprinting and
what it's called now is a Content
recognition or automatic content
recognition it's a very new space
actually up until last year no one even
knew what that meant and now it's
actually becoming something where you're
gonna find trade shows and so forth so
it's called a CR there's a lot of
companies in this space but in the
beginning we tried to do video search
again the new search wasn't so great
because YouTube had 80% of all the
videos so there's no reason to use
anything but YouTube search we quickly
figured that out that no one was using
it and that kind of technology video
fingerprint technology first found
buyers content owners broadcasters they
became anti-piracy so we actually
pivoted very quickly to anti-piracy for
short-term revenue and we start being
you know one of the best companies in
Asia and we worked with the MPA there's
actually and you guys probably don't
know this but the content owners run
something called movie laps and the MPA
runs movie labs and they actually work
on this kind of technology just to
prevent you from downloading illegal
files on the Internet
and of course at the time Korea's one of
these hot beds I don't know if you know
about megaupload you know and Kim calm
hundreds of these sites exists in Korea
and they're making money that's the
difference bit torrent no one's making
money out of it
these sites dower kind of web storage
based solutions someone actually makes
money people pay for a subscription they
pay to download so we actually start
filtering hundreds these solutions and
we evolved to your video distribution
platform in O nine we actually came
profitable from doing that from
anti-piracy and so forth in 2010 we
raised a series B from KT capital
Stonebridge ventures and Softbank
ventures and we you know we've grew very
quickly when a CR became something our
technology is matured and scalable
because of anti piracy and today
anything you call second-screen
experiences our first screen experiences
you guys probably shows on your phone or
SoundHound
and that's exactly what a CR means you
can listen that's what shows omnes it
listens to any audio feed and compares
it to the actual music files and it
figures out what you're listening to
what we're talking about what first
screen is you can have technology like
that for video you can see what you're
watching and figure out what it does and
now this kind technology is being
embedded into your phone into your
television so that your device is
content-aware that's what we're calling
it and so it by concept is similar to
what a gps chip does for your phone or
for your device it lets your phone know
where you are content recognition lets
your device know what you're listening
to or what you're watching so it's a
very new concept something maybe the
first time and so we're expanding
everywhere so in Korea the number one
Shazam type app is powered by our
solution in Japan we work with actually
we do work with dense ooh again white
labeling our solution so that
advertising campaigns say you are
watching the Olympics and coca-cola
wants to advertise well you download an
app you click in I'm watching fencing
right now you get some
points we powered apps like that and
campaigns like that throughout Korea and
Japan
and in the u.s. we are now working on
the same kind of second-screen
experiences along with the television
work that we're doing in a CR so that's
what answers does and because of this
vision and the growth of this market
well I don't know why that just did that
at the end of 2011 we actually were
acquired by Korea Telecom and Softbank
being the original investor in the
company remained as a minority
shareholder and it's kind of working as
a JV right now even though kt owns most
of shares and that's kind of where i
came back and when we were negotiating
the acquisition i said it's been a long
time since I've been home let me open an
office in the US to do the business I'm
working on which is why I'm here today
and I'm running the subsidiary out here
in America as well as the kpop
subsidiary that we run so that's the
last 10 years to startups and a little
bit of consulting in between and I
wanted to end with a few thoughts from
my perspective as someone who was in
Korean doing startups in Korea
especially 10 years ago I strongly felt
the starting point was the Korean
government um and it's easy here in the
Silicon Valley to say governments in
Asia or around the world funding these
universities these you know digital
parks that doesn't work I think it helps
a lot it's it's the first round of
funding you're gonna get you know
there's a process to do it you just
supply there's no strings attached why
not you know the government's not going
to take shares your company you're gonna
get you know hundred thousand maybe a
little bit more just for writing an idea
down maybe some technology so I think
that's a really wonderful starting point
here you of course you have the seed
investors angel investors in Asia still
the government gives a lot of help to
young startups the second thing is going
to Korea that was interesting to me
Korean business really has its own rules
or Asian business in general but I
really believe that people kind of lump
Asia
all into one group Korea is very
different from Japan from China from
Singapore from rest of Southeast Asia
and ten years ago when we're doing this
and we're very young it's actually very
difficult to be young and starting the
company because you're breaking a lot of
barriers there there's a hierarchy of
age
there's hierarchy of titles it's built
into the language that there's several
layers of respect in the way you speak
you have to learn all of those things
you have to learn though about and it's
not you know again there's some good
things about being an entrepreneur I
think ignoring this is is a problem
learning about the working culture is
different I mean I'm sure a lot of
people talked about stories of everyone
working really late say in Japan in
Korea there's kind of a frantic working
style and it's not so much staying late
actually what I feel about Korean
working culture is always available like
I feel like you're always available to
the people you work with you're always
available to the your clients you're
always available to investors that means
that there is no time in your day that
you shouldn't be able to be reached and
that's very unique to being in Korea I
feel like um when you go to Japan people
might be working late but the subways
are done by 10:00 p.m. whenever that is
there in Korea at anytime someone could
call and you just hop in a cab and be
right there they expect that the other
thing with negotiation Korea it's a
little bit different I think David will
give a different perspective on this in
negotiation a lot of times people say
that in Asia you negotiate and like well
when does it begin I feel like in Korea
getting to the handshake means that okay
now we can start talking about how to do
business rather than it's the end of the
deal and I think that's an important
thing to remember so we'll talk about
this more as we go but I definitely felt
there's some differences in the way
Koreans approach business and how it's
supposed to be done the third thing is
the chapel influenced chapels are the
large companies in Korea the mega
companies that run everything mm-hmm
Samsung LG in America and you're
is a consumer electronics company in
Korea that's not the case you can buy
Samsung consumer electronics like
fridges and phones and stuff but you can
get an apartment you can get your life
insurance from them you can buy car
everything in your life can actually be
Samsung and you know the banks they're
the part of Samsung family you know
another brother or sister runs the
entertainment company someone else runs
the malls that you go to and then the
Mart that you go to the Walmart that you
go to so it's very powerful there for
startups what what that means that the
approach the strategic investments is
very different as if you take money from
Samsung you're not gonna get bought by
LG right you take money from certain
strategic investors they expect very
different things from you you from you
then you would get here
technology deals with the big companies
a lot of companies I've talked to have
worked with and part of investing in
they end up becoming just a development
shop a lot of companies in Korea end up
like that you'll start a company you
have great technology you sign a deal
and you basically signed over your
company for the next five years you're
just building technology like that so
it's it's definitely something to be
aware of starting company in Korea the
fourth point is that the venture
ecosystem is very very young and it's
very different ten years ago from now
and again angels didn't really exist
that much ten years ago
they're starting now you're there's a
few sources of seed and angel financing
other than government there are steps
along the chain you know you can get a
few million dollars from some VCS and
then you can potentially exit but again
this is all very new and the fifth thing
is that you have to maximize the
advantages of being in Korea and
whatever that is engineering talent the
way people consume again a lot of these
cool payment models were created in
Korea the the freemium gaming model I
mean I keep on going back to gaming is
very interesting and even the industry
we were in for anti-piracy on the web
storage they innovated that years before
anyone else did before megaupload
around I mean it was it's a
billion-dollar business in Korea when we
were doing it I mean a billion dollars
worth of illegal downloads and that's
not calculating how much the downloads
are worth that's actually how many how
much money was exchanging hands over
that from consumers to these companies
so I think those are kind of thoughts on
entrepreneurship in Korea and I want to
leave here with five more thoughts on
going from Silicon Valley to Asia
personally I found Korea amazing last
ten years have been just all growth from
buildings that were there the way the
working culture is and the the
technology development that's it's been
a privilege to be living Korea I feel
like a lot of people you know now it's
the theme you go to Asia there's a huge
opportunity it's awesome it's true
wherever those changes opportunity but I
don't necessarily think that it's better
for startups a lot of people say it's
just better go do it um Silicon Valley
is still the best machinery I mean
there's more talent here funding you can
exit large nice weather and then when
and if you decide be impersonally to go
to Asia to run a startup
one of the most important things in
Korean in Asia in general is you know
again learn the language it's important
and try not to be too ignorant in the
effort matters effort of trying to learn
matters a lot and then don't make the
mistake of thinking Korea or Japan are
the same or China or Hong Kong any of
these countries they're saying
everywhere is different you've got to
learn where you're gonna be so that's
really my thoughts and that's everything
I wanted to talk about today before we
talk about what's happening now and what
will happen next ten years with David in
his perspective all right thanks thank
you could stay there
thanks for the great presentation I take
notes with my phone I'm not checking
emails just in case you're wondering so
I think what interesting point that he
made and I'll sit here while we have a
mock fireside chat is uh it's kind of
the the rarity of how many entrepreneurs
that are not Korean can actually make it
there because I know there's one other
guy Daniel Shin you might know him he
was the founder of ticket monster he's a
korean-american but he went there I
think three or four years ago did sort
of a Groupon clone and sold it for like
four hundred million within like a year
and a half sold the LivingSocial and so
I think a lot of guys followed like the
summer brothers from Germany built a
clone shop out there people started to
do this similar thing but I think aside
from the cloning you know wave you know
you see some innovation actually going
there but a lot of people that were
educated here learning best practices
and going there did you sort of see that
as a first wave as well or do you think
it's it's just that that sort of time
frame when it was happening and do you
see more sort of originality coming out
of Korea I I think what you're saying
that trend is very important the fact
that the available opportunities and the
incentives that go back to Korea are now
there it's you know it's a career option
for people before it wasn't you know if
you're educated here you should stay
here because your life is better and
that's what your parents told you going
back to Korea now is a viable option in
fact a lucrative one for some people and
I think that's an important trend you
know will that keep it running over the
next ten years 15 years 20 years I think
it will so you're going to be able to
bring talent back into Korea and you
know when I talk to people like Daniel
like why did you do it why did you come
back and instead of joining Groupon
start your own clone he's like there's a
big opportunity there's a big chance and
I would say ten years ago that wasn't
such a great chance whereas now it is
for entrepreneurs yeah I think
ironically a lot of entrepreneurs there
they all want to come here they all
think this is you know the the end-all
and it's biggest market and in many
cases we have to coach them out of
coming here because that you know
they're really you know they're more
successful in their own backyard focus
on that and I think just there's a big
culture learning curve over them when
they come over here just the way that
Silicon Valley is run and you know the
very pi standards in many ways but also
just the language you know small things
like that which brings me to the point
about ecosystem so I know one thing that
I see very parent with startups here but
then you look at ones in China Korea is
that everyone here it's like being in
Detroit everyone's in the same industry
everyone's supporting each other in tech
so it's a lot I think in that sense much
easier to succeed as this entrepreneur
here being that you know you're on the
ground in Korea you know there's lots of
fragmentation startups are still seen as
very risky if you're an entrepreneur you
know it's hard to get married because
they think you know you're not working
at Samsung and to your point earlier
what do you think is missing there from
from the point of eco you talked a
little bit about it but and I see some
as well and I'll mention some after you
give your comments um I just think it
takes time and the ecosystem needs to
develop one of the it's
self-perpetuating what's happening now
is that why it's small is because a lot
of the early VCS now they're starting
their own firms and able to raise from
LPS so a lot of people I worked with
I'd say Softbank now they're you know
they were associates then now they're
the partners that their firms or the
founding members so you know it just
takes time for entrepreneurs to grow out
for the VCS to grow out and for more
people like yourself actually raising
funds the people capable of raising
money and saying and having the
credibility to invest in that ecosystem
so again it's you know ten years ago
this wasn't available now it is starting
to be an even though it's small is it's
great to see incubators happening and
funds that are come along with
mentorship and advice as well yeah I
mean the investors that would say are
pretty savvy they're they're they're not
gonna invest in something they know will
fail and you know they I think in terms
of you know innovation they don't really
think of it that way think of more
what's my return gonna be especially
when it's more of the angel level you
know early-stage guy I think more
strategic investors will think about
what are we getting out of the valley
what are we learning but definitely I
think once there's more of that trust
with the early-stage
it'll happen more and definitely with
government getting involved this which
is my next topic I see pros and cons and
I know you said it was good and you know
with the new
president in Korea she's really pushing
for small medium businesses to go global
for each government agency to have a
budget to go towards start-up companies
which i think is good because everyone
thinks that you know they it's being
it's going to be supported from the
beginning but I think the bad part of it
is that no one's vetting the deals like
an investor would and that creates I
think a lot of zombie companies once
they get that funding from the
government and then they run out of
money within like six months to a year
you know they go to an investor in he's
like you know you guys should have never
been born I mean your business model is
not right and you know all these stuff
that's sort of missing from sort of
baseline startup companies right so I
have you say have you seen that to be
the case or do you think that that in
itself will just you know wash out over
time and things will be okay III think
it's a difference in perspective I mean
free money is great from the
entrepreneurs perspective from a macro
perspective of is it good for the
ecosystem I don't know
right I don't know the answer it's a
policy question whether or not that
actually encourages but it you know
again our startups all the stops I've
done have been born out of government
funding right so that's why I look at it
positively I have seen a lot of terrible
companies come out of it but then again
I've seen a lot of terrible companies
come out of private funding as well so
right it's it's a policy question I
would say that in Korea's case it has
been effective largely because a lot of
these zombie companies may not be
innovative but they create development
strengths and engineering strengths that
like I said become zombie companies
developing technology for the bigger
companies it's an interesting dynamic
going there but that is that is what I
see is happening and obviously with the
right people like you and those
companies you know can do the best thing
with the money I know there's some other
guys who you know they have certain we
caught requirements from the government
that they have to spend the money on
surplus stuff like you know buy you know
vegetable oil and it's a you know it's a
tech company and they've got all these
bottles of vegetable oil in the back
they have to buy from the government I
know these little loopholes and little
interesting things but I think it's like
you know the time the tide rises for
everybody with our accelerator case
startup initially it was government
funded but then we broke out of that and
we got money from Google and one other
conglomerate in Korea and basically they
said just run it on your own you guys do
what you have to do and that was the
best path for us but I think yeah I
think with a lot of startups and they
you know getting that getting to the
programs that are you know have fewer
fewer availability and investors who are
more or less savvy I would say yeah
having money from government is a good
sort of way to kick-start that and
definitely if you could talk to them
about that more over there I think would
help get the fear out of people and
especially what startups that are coming
from that side of a fence so in terms of
financing and we'll talk a little bit
about your view I mean I'm curious to
hear because I know in the early days
with with entrepreneurs that you know
very draconian terms you know if you
lose the money you have to pay it back
personally you know they could take your
house I've heard those kind of stories
and use it sounded sort of like that
with you I'm seeing this slow shift
toward more normal looking trim sheets
where it's more of a you know
convertible note like you'd see in the
valley are you seeing that shift as well
and and what do you think of from the
viewpoint of where entrepreneurs are in
Korea and you know the ones that are
making it over there how do you view
that the economy going on yeah I mean I
definitely think there's a huge
progression in terms and the deals that
I've taken my first one ten years ago
was written Korean and it was terrible
basically I was me and the other founder
was personally liable the reason we got
out of it was I made a very good
decision early on and I asked it to be
written in English because I wasn't a
native Korean speaker because of that
actually a lot of terms were gone and
you know I had it reviewed so again when
I was looking at this the Korean sheet I
don't I didn't sign it was one of the
worst things ever right for an
entrepreneur by the second time there's
certain VCS now that are like real visas
like again Softbank venture Stonebridge
there's new visas at that stage that can
give you that 1 to 5 million target
range for a Series A and their terms are
much better but even 5 years ago when I
took money from Softbank and Stonebridge
and so forth some of the terms were not
quite as nice as they were here and
because we were doing our second startup
and I was part of soft banks when we got
out of it but again you know the way
ratchets work you know some little
detail that they won't tell you
and the way some of the bonds would
convert if you took that route it was
definitely not as nice as here at this
point but again it takes a lot of time
because it takes a lot of entrepreneurs
to fight those terms and a lot of
companies to have you know learn from
that mistake before the entrepreneurs
start pushing back on those terms
I think Korea's getting to that point
where there's an inflection point where
the B C's understand that it's better
not to handcuff all the entrepreneurs
mm-hmm let them be safe in taking their
money yeah exactly right and I think the
more that they see they meet with other
entrepreneurs from the valley that are
used to different practices that you
know they want the same term because it
just creates just it it's much more is
it you know free thinking and we'll just
work on your startup without worrying
about I have to pay somebody back and
the point of of that I mean with our
accelerator we we definitely you know
promote community so we bring like
mentors and advisors from the US who are
entrepreneurs over to Korea to meet with
them and mainly not to teach them what
to do but to just share their thoughts I
think entrepreneurs love love meeting
each other they have the same kind of
problems and because of that I'm seeing
this change in thinking where people
think it's not just a Western thing it's
really a global thing being an
entrepreneur and while you were in Korea
because I know it's very you know
insular in the sense of culture I mean
how are you able to you know being that
you're not Korean
I think I'd asked earlier how are you
able to keep sort of your way of doing
things and and I found sometimes that
when you don't speak Korean to them it
it actually makes business a little
easier because you take all the
formalities out it was at the same case
for you yeah I mean I definitely felt
while I was there there's some novelty
factor in like why are you here
and I think that helps a lot I believe
that I tried a lot in the way I've
learned the language the customs I mean
there's going out to company dinners I
you know I've been back working here for
six months and our subsidiary and I
haven't really gone out for more than a
beer I mean Korea you're expected to
stay out all night karaoke with your
team members things like that and
especially with dealing with your
investors or more the elderly managers
that you will see
you have to treat everyone with a
certain amount of respect even if they
don't understand what you're trying to
do and buy doom then shown the effort of
doing that I think that helps a lot in
Korea and I would say Asia in general
but Korea it's very important so for me
to gain that structure it's it's like
wow he's really willing to learn the
language try everything and you know try
all the different foods live octopus so
you know you're willing to have an open
mind going there it's going to help did
you have to drink a lot yeah I am
familiar of all different types of soju
yeah I think that's one one requirement
for people the final thing I wanted to
talk about was more of like content I
know that's from a Content perspective
in Korea you know how you the Korean
Wave you know be it kpop and dramas when
I visited Taiwan Japan China I noticed
the influence there already it was
really interesting and you know you
couldn't deny it yet but definitely it's
something that Korea has to recognize is
a big byproduct of an export they have
right you guys are sort of in that vein
and I've done some work with game
companies and they've all you know
looked at Korea for that kind of stuff
is that something that you think is
making Korea more interesting or do you
think that it's it's more just a trend
and you know there's other interesting
things about Korea that could be
innovative and things that we should
look at you know I definitely believe
that the cultural exports of Korea the
idea of you know the Korean Wave is very
interesting I run soompi.com which is of
course a and English and other language
site for Korean pop culture the fans are
everywhere and it's it helps improve the
image globally we work with the Korea
Tourism Organization it makes more
interesting um it's an important
progression to make because there were a
lot of exports say from hong kong or
japan before this right no enemy and so
for for Korea to establish itself as a
powerhouse globally an understanding of
the way to culture works why it's unique
and the respect for it is very important
for people to want to work in Korea or
work with Korean companies and that's
the same for Japan you know a lot of
people understood okay here's j-pop
here's anime okay that's interesting
it's unique I think Korea has made great
strides in that I mean 200 million views
on Psy's new video
I don't know if you guys in the condom
style now this gentleman that was huge
within a couple days so just having that
exposure he's gonna help a lot yeah and
one final enough from my side with the
accelerator we take applicants from
Korea but we had 150 yourself against
and we chose about 10 but I 150 maybe
1/3 were from international so we chose
actually to one guy from the US and one
from Hong Kong who is part of Y
Combinator before but we're seeing its
global I think people just want to be in
certain countries that have certain
advantage what they're doing whether
it's mobile or gaming or whatever and it
happens that people identify it that
with with that kind of business and it's
becoming less of a barrier and I think
easier for foreigners to do business
there as well as coming this way which I
didn't really talk about I mean maybe I
mean now coming back you know is there
sort of culture shock that you have and
do you notice big differences in an
entrepreneur ISM on both sides of the
ocean coming back and there's not a
culture shock I mean I grew up in this
area but definitely the style of
business is different in Korea you can
make a phone call you can reach almost
anyone very quickly and they say Silicon
Valley similar you know I guess you
could go into LinkedIn and within one
degree there's pretty much everyone you
need to meet there but the pace is so
different and the negotiation style is
very different you know you almost call
you all directly exactly there's no
emails there I mean it's fewer and then
the the American conference call system
I I don't know why we all live within an
hour of each other and we're always on
conference calls right and so there's
always one person has to mute out on
their Bluetooth like it's very different
and it used to be okay that that's the
way it's done
where's Africa on Korea's you value
having the face-to-face meeting in that
interaction I don't know if it's better
or not it's just different that was kind
of the big difference for me mm-hmm
right I think at this point we'll open
it up to the audience if you guys have
any questions or comments we'd love to
hear hopefully we can answer yes
actually I'm not particularly sure about
how bankruptcy law works otherwise who
would have done that instead of yeah
yeah but I remember at the time this was
2005 when I was considering when we were
considering bankruptcy that it was very
similar because most of the Korean
system is modeled after the u.s. one so
I think the cream bankruptcy system is
about the same but I am NOT an expert by
any means you say with the top two or
three challenges Korean startups are a
sentence would face when coming to
Silicon Valley from my perspective and
yeah you didn't want your perspective so
a lot of Korean companies have failed
here both large and small
the big ones of course you know when I
don't know if you guys heard of it but
the number one social network before
Facebook was Cyworld in Korea they built
a huge team they failed to come here but
then there's a lot of smart smaller
startups that failed to come here as
well and then you're like well maybe
it's because they don't understand
Silicon Valley well no they hired a
whole bunch of people from here right so
it's not because of that it's just
different yeah it's the same reason why
for a long time a lot of companies
couldn't get into Korea culturally it's
just different and you have to
understand that when there's a
difference in culture you have to take
the strengths and remove the weaknesses
a lot of people don't do that they just
copy it and that's where it was weak one
of the just like David's talk about take
a monster versus Groupon very recently
when Groupon tried to enter Korea there
was a smaller company by a Korean
American
that's called tikka monster and they
became number one even though Groupon
poured bunch of money offered to buy
them because they approached it
differently and they were able to be
flexible now on the way back here the
companies are in Korea trying to enter
the US market there they are almost
always trying to clone another US idea
and saying we can do cheaper it's not
good proposition so that's very common
mistakes if you're gonna do it you have
to really commit to the market you're in
and I still feel that a lot of Korean
companies don't don't think of it that
way
just think of it when one is culture
obviously language they're not used to
being out of their element it's very
homogeneous in Korea one guy that I met
it was at GSB here and he he founded a
company called biggie and he didn't
speak much English but he was stubborn
and determined like I'm gonna figure
this out I'm gonna get to know people
here so he survived and went back to
Korea eventually and then his company
got big money from injuries and you
think pretty well so pretty rare for you
know barely english-speaking CEO but
then there's other companies that sort
of you know failed immediately like
Cyworld couldn't local up a culture in
the mindset and then also the network
like they don't know investors they
don't know Partners over here in fact
the main question I get from folks from
Korea is how do I meet you know Sequoia
how do I meet this angel investor how do
I make a partnership with Google and
even if I introduce them there's no
conversation going on there and there's
no follow-up because there's just a wall
of you know differences right and
culture shock so and for the VCS two of
those guys are used to seeing you know
the sort of top notch a level
entrepreneur that's you know based here
and so it's it's on both sides and in
many cases we have to broker that and
that's sort of what I do but definitely
it's I think those are the two main
reasons I have a Korean friend of
staying with us right habits the surgeon
used to being a rotation at Stanford and
we've been talking a lot about
differences in culture and it's very
clear to me if I'm curious to hear from
you what lessons could American founders
an American startups learn from Korean
founders and stars but find that every
single take up around the world some
kind of innate advantage they have
because of what they contend with in
their culture in the earth
ah my perspective after being Korea for
a long time and still running a stop
there
Koreans have like I said that Frank
ain't working style is very powerful
I mean it's when they say here and that
iteration is very important
it's like built into the way Koreans are
I mean they're just they're constantly
iterating the way they're working and
the other thing is the way that the
relationships are built it's it's so
much yeah I think it's probably born out
of the modernist culture but it's very
powerful to get ideas or to work with
people your network is really fast when
we're recruiting it's I know people and
then BAM you know we're able to grow
very quickly and get really good talent
and though people say the risk-taking
isn't there and so the kind of last
thing is that there is some risk taking
because if you know someone who's doing
the startup you can get them in enjoying
you without like all the incentives and
so forth they're willing to take that
jump and for for me and the teams I've
worked with we continue working with
each other and we continue to get more
people take jumps with us I think that's
very powerful I think in short like the
affinity that goes on because when I'm
there I mean obviously I'm
korean-american but they identify moved
with when I'm as a Korean when I'm there
you just included and when I bring
others whether they're Korean or not
from the US in that group they're
included so we they go to lunch together
they go drinking the other and you build
this like human bond that's very very
very strong and I noticed you know in
other cultures you know or maybe even in
the states you know you work and then
you you going to your family and you
kind of separate work from from your
life but there it's it's very sort of
intertwined and it consumes everything
you know your whole lifestyle is
consumed with your your your group at at
work in fact most of the companies there
at twelve o'clock they'll shut the
lights off m.a.c because everyone's
going to lunch and so you can't just sit
there you know I'll be sitting in the
cube and then you know it's dark and we
have to find my way out but it's because
they want everyone to go at a certain
time and be together
there's just mobs of people so I think
that forces you to just be
interconnected and that in turn kind of
helps you become more motivated in some
ways they think and that feel like
you're left out you're like a loners I'm
going
like that's I think that's fact that a
group doesn't go together at lunch at
the same time here felt like right are
your being not included but one person
tanks for everybody versus you know
Dutch here you know it's more common to
do that
all things what effect is North Korea
having on South Korean business and
entrepreneurship well I mean I remember
like that every couple months there be
bomb drills and so forth um
the most obvious aspect like I said is
that they have to keep a standing
military and that two-year requirement
is huge they've tried they give
exemptions so for the high-tech industry
they try to let entre mean not
entrepreneurs but engineers not have to
go the military and only do one month
and serve those two years as kind of
cheap labor for startups and that's
worth a lot to a degree because you
don't lose two years of your prime and
actually a lot of engineers in our
company in my last two companies
actually went through those kind of
programs and got exemptions but the
broader aspect is that you're delaying
the workforce reaching productivity for
two years and that's obviously the big
big difference I was just there like
last week for about two and a half weeks
prior one all the news is going on and
you know you don't really hear about it
there so much at all people are so used
to maids from Palo Alto to San Francisco
it's about that that distance from Seoul
to the border so it's just it's very
unconscious in your in your mind I think
as as I was trying to bring in some guys
for business meetings from the states
but they didn't want to come because of
what was going on do we wanted to wait
and see but I think definitely inside of
Korea there's less anxiety and people
just are you know they're more concerned
about the weather frankly than they are
about nukes or you know North Korea
you guys had talked about this briefly
before we started the program in terms
of the emergence of accelerators just
stole something that's quite new in
Korea how that maybe would have played
out very differently for you Sherman if
we didn't have accelerators in Korea
maybe want to talk a little bit more
about them I'll speak really briefly
before David takes this way I'll just
say that I would much rather I've taken
money from David when starting these
companies then oh wait I did get one oh
I don't know but no actually um yeah a
start-up in this new wave of incubators
and money is very important and I kind
of want to see what your ideas are what
you're gonna be doing storm right now
because Korea's a lot more open than
before the government's pushing startup
companies you have a lot of
entrepreneurs there that are from you
know they've been schooled all over or
they've worked in different companies if
we we had a profile of all the
entrepreneurs that came to our last
program there from you know schools in
the state schools in China and all over
and worked at all different kinds of you
know Apple and and it's just it's a
diverse pool now so it's not just local
but I think we're trying to get more
deeper into the local networks of folks
who are just wanting to work in that
safe job at Samsung or LG and find that
talent but I think I still think the
mindset is still you know it has some
peeling of the onion to go but now more
corporates and other sponsors that's the
size of the government are now
interested in putting money into these
even investors so Sequoia I talked to
them a few months ago they're like you
know we love what's going on in the
mobile messaging area like because they
invested in whatsapp and you look at I
don't figurative Kakao Talk that's like
the number one messaging app in Korea
there's line which is n H ends but those
are driving social networking in Korea
in the in Asia now it's not so much
Facebook people are leaving and they're
doing more sort of one-to-one with a
very smaller network and just they're
playing games on it so with that
phenomenon there definitely it's feeling
more entrepreneurs to get more excited
about doing a start-up because there's
less barriers to entry in Korea but I
think government you know private
investors guys who've made money in tech
international companies coming in is
feeling this kind of fear
of accelerators that are happening so
there's more money there and obviously
more talented people who can help that
or curate these programs you know
getting involved because there's some
upside that they can see or some benefit
to getting involved there and more
excitement frankly so that's kind of
what I'm seeing that out in the last
year or two but government's still
excited but kind of everyone's working
in unison so I think that's what's
making a lot of noise
what's the accelerator I have I have one
question for you David and what I'm
interested in understanding from your
perspective is where do you see the exit
market developing in Korea because it's
very different from here you know yeah
the windows for exiting in Silicon
Valley are very different from Korea and
over time and it's changed a lot as well
like an exit like what we did with Korea
Telecom
I mean Korea telecom never really bought
companies like ours before at that
valuation especially so I can't see like
with your investments at the early stage
you know why why have you concentrated
on that and where do you see your
companies going towards well we see huge
obviously we call that sort of the dark
ages right now where people are meaning
to learn how to do a start-up and go
through all that sort of iterations of
that kind of like here but you know 10
years ago and now there's this you know
huge learning curve people are getting
it but someone's got to pay for that
sort of Dark Age period which is these
incubators the government which is great
people are learning about it
but I think the real money that's going
to be there meaning from M&A or from
investment I started to come and slowly
because they're seeing these exits
whether it's your company as a reference
people talk about your company as well
as ticket monster is being hey these are
the you know best-case scenarios and
sort of looking at the you know the
sectors that they're in and I think that
you know the way that we look at
accelerators right now is really more of
just you know learning but finding this
sort of gems within the portfolio that
that will you know that will succeed
whether it's in Korea or going abroad
even with Y Combinator I mean if you
look at the hit rate it's still pretty
low I mean you could probably count on
two hands in the past couple of batches
how many have actually exited or getting
further financing so but I think that's
sort of the nature of accelerators it's
that people will take something from it
or they'll meet other founders and start
a new company and some wolf created in
the next day or B&B or Dropbox but in
Korea that I think they're still coming
up with these their own
innovations and through time and there
you know become serial entrepreneurs but
I think in the next couple of years
we'll see it in a bigger and better
things happening again it's a small
country with a small you know sort of
number of people compared to elsewhere
but it's becoming more global which is
what I think is interesting but in order
to do that they have to meet others that
are abroad and learn the markets yeah
why don't you guys think thoughts on
maybe comparing you know the recent
success of Samsung and LG compared to
kind of declining dominance of
electronics companies in Japan they are
there any particular maybe qualities
from Korea and you know the
entrepreneurship or business culture
that you think are really giving them
lots of strengths right now in this in
this era timer
I'll answer quickly first my I mean
speculating on why Samsung is successful
it's so many different moving factors
right I mean they made the right
investments so I wouldn't say it's
something like okay there's a specific
cultural you know thing that makes them
more successful and again we don't know
how this is gonna play out over the next
20 years IT moves very quickly and the
one interesting thing is there was an
article I believe is The Times or Wall
Street Journal about the founder of
Samsung and the idea that they're
paranoid and I think that is the one
thing I see that works really well like
there's always gonna be something
different you know my phone is the
Galaxy Note which everyone tells me is
ridiculous looking and they're gonna
make a bigger one and there's never
going to stop and I think that's one
thing that will serve well we don't know
if the investments are gonna be right
but never thinking that this is the best
thing ever
I that's the one quality I think at
Samsung LG or the Korean companies that
will really help them succeed in the
future yeah I think part of it is also
there's you know a little chip on their
shoulders you know about these other
companies they always feel like we have
to compete and we have to you know and
and I but when you look inside the
company like I've met a lot of guys at
Samsung is that they think very
globally in fact they've hired like
their top president and a bunch of EVPs
they're all they've all studied abroad
and they're all from overseas to some
degree and that's very rare for a Korean
cable company usually it's all family
like LG it's all family and and I think
it sort of stunts the growth of a
company that's the typical chaebol
companies that can a cousin's are
running it and but the fact that they've
embraced outside outsiders and outside
management I think has really helped a
lot to make it a better company so you
look at like your Samsung LG whose
there's like not a single Korean person
there they've all got local people
writing them and understanding them so
even in Palo Alto I don't have to hear
that they have two big innovation
centers coming in one on University
where the old borders is another one on
Sand Hill it's gonna be more focused on
you know semiconductors and that kind of
thing so they're really making you know
the throwing a lot of money at the at
the market and hopefully we'll you know
we'll see what happens
better for worse so because of the kind
of dinosaur companies like Samsung and
LG in South Korea so do you have
something in mind to be should be a boy
should avoid serving another so should
we avoid certain kind of business
mothers or business leaders in South
Korea because of the conditions between
the startup company and
Tennison convinced actually Samsung and
LG are covering a lot many captioning
and services nowadays my question is so
do you
should we oh boy stuck to these regions
I wouldn't build the phone this is were
really quick to sense because a lot of
startups you do worry about Samsung and
LG obviously SK but Hynix recently the
big semiconductor memory company because
they want to be like Samsung in many
ways right they want to own that whole
ecosystem because they owned the whole
they're the majority telco in Korea I
think there's less fear because you
stepping up and doing more invest M&A I
mean even their incubator in and uh
pulse is a little bit controversial
because they want to invest in companies
but sort of writer first refusal get be
given to Samsung so down the road they
can buy them but I don't know who's
gonna buy that right they might not like
that but I think they're getting better
at hey let's just fun
companies and if they do great well
that's great learn from them and the
same no they're stepping up and doing
more equity there's a couple of
acquisitions like last year that they've
done but again it's very rare and even
with Katie that's even that's super rare
I think there's there's say open their
minds up a bit more and hopefully that
won't affect startups not to want to do
so but they're you know they're moving
not only in the hardware but softer
media side that's also growing so you
know I think anyone can be a target if
you're in Korea because you need those
partners to to succeed it to some degree
yeah I mean I it's the same kind of
thought line but what I believe a star
should avoid is not in a specific
industry or something they should just
avoid getting the contract that makes
them just a shop for Samsung or shop for
LG it happens a lot yeah happens a lot
and that's really the biggest thing to
avoid for us we're actually Samsung LG
have a very good long tradition of
investing companies that's how it
happens right for their partners but my
company actually and I can't tell you
details but we we do work with Samson a
very long-term relationship in multiple
areas and we don't have an investment
from them so it means that they're
starting to be looking at that but to
date most of the time they'll invest in
the company before they partner with
them but it's changing
I won't be as worried about that it's in
fact an advantage
you